lena volochine on vous retrouve sur
place que retenir de cette première
rencontre
on retient à la fois une volonté de
dialogue avec un ton plutôt diplomate
mais aussi une certaine fermeté de la
part du nouveau gouvernement fédéral
allemand vis-à-vis de la russie dans
leur conférence de presse commune à
l'issue de cette rencontre sa
représentante anna lena barbeuk n'a pas
évité les sujets qui fâchent elle a
rappelé notamment la nécessité pour tous
les états membres de respecter les
décisions de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme elle a explicitement
mentionné à les affaires de l'opposant
russe alexeï navalni est le cas de la
liquidation de lo n'diaye mémorial
prononcées par la justice russe en
décembre dernier ce qui a fait
grandement réagir à la communauté
internationale et puis au coeur de ces
discussions évidemment vous le disiez le
dossier ukrainien la ministre allemande
a là aussi explicitement mentionné la
présence de plus de cent mille soldats
russes à la frontière avec l'ukraine
comme une menace nous n'avons pas choisi
cette situation mais nous n'allons pas
l'éviter a affirmé la ministre allemande
alors sa visite après celle à kiev hier
elle place une fois de plus un ce
dossier entre la russie et l'ukraine au
coeur des préoccupations des européens
du moment alors que la semaine dernière
rappelons le à les pourparlers entre la
russie et les etats unis puis entre la
russie et l'otan ont échoué à aboutir à
un accord
le but pour l'allemagne désormais mais
aussi pour la france c'est de se
replacer dans les discussions autour de
ce dossier crucial pour la sécurité
européenne
alors au coeur des pourparlers il ya le
fait de raviver ce format 10 de
normandie qui inclus au départ la france
l'allemagne la russie et l'ukraine sur
ce dossier du conflit ukrainien dans la
région du dombass à l'est du pays format
qui est au point mort depuis 2019 mais
aujourd'hui toutes les parties y compris
la russie d'ailleurs affirment leur
volonté de le voir remis sur les rails
pour revenir aux négociations entre
européens russes et ukrainiens alors
même que vous le disiez un par ailleurs
le secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken c'est non seulement entretenu
aujourd'hui dans la foulée avec le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov mais s'apprête aussi à se
rendre à kiev et à berlin pour tenter
lui aussi de son côté de faire avancer
ce dossier merci elena volochine 2